okay good evening everyone and welcome
to this meeting of the executive
um first of all to note attendances I've
had an apology substance from counselors
Karina Carter James Slater and James
Wright are there any apologies
yes
apologies from Jill McGregor and Corey
for it today thank you thank you very
much I apologies I've also been received
from Graham Bentley thank you very much
Alex
okay uh do we have any Declarations of
Interest
okay so I'm happy to move the minutes of
the meeting held on the 13th of March
2023 which seems like a lifetime ago uh
or all those in favor
thank you very much and I've not been
notified of any questions from the
public today no there are no questions
so in that case I'm going to move on to
item five
um are there any Matters from Council or
overview and scrutiny committees
councilor acting yeah
thank you leader
um yeah just a couple of things
um on the 10th of July
um scrutiny are holding an extraordinary
meeting to discuss the proposals to
replace the full-time firefighters on
the night shift with Encore firefighters
at the sale fire station
we have invited the GM Fire Chief and
the trade unions to put their views
forward
clearly the plans seem to me because
I've heard in the Grapevine that this
could be quite controversial
um but we hope to be able to give the
leader and the executive uh our thoughts
and our recommendations from that
meeting
and secondly the first ordinary scrutiny
meeting for the new
Municipal year is on the 12th of July
and we will be discussing a work program
at that meeting for the year and the
leader yourself your good self has
agreed to attend the meeting to look at
what the executive's priorities are
so that's it really thank you very much
for that councilor Acton yes the meeting
the special meeting of excusing will be
very important and I know that there'll
be several members who will be wishing
to ask questions about the changes being
proposed by the fire and rescue service
and I for one will value the feedback
that we get from scrutiny and the
questions that will be asked for you
right it is a it is something that we
need to probe understand and then submit
a consultation to so thank you for that
Council right and I also yes can I just
uh say on on the record really
everybody's invited to come along to the
meeting particularly I think those Ward
counselors that feel that they've got an
interest in the whole
um
proposals that have been put forward
thank you that's that's a very important
thing to note cancer acting that it is
open for people to put forward their
questions particularly people in the
wards that are impacted by these changes
that have been proposed by the fire and
rescue service so thank thank you for
that and I look forward to working with
you and the security committee over the
next 12 months as I know all the
executive will be so thank you moving on
to the substantive part of the uh the
meeting then item six which is to
consider a paper on the way forward for
electric vehicle infrastructure in
Trafford and I'm going to pass over to
the executive member for climate change
Aiden Williams
thank you chair I'll take it the
committee has read the report which
essentially seeks to provide an update
on the progress being made around the
electric vehicle charging infrastructure
in the Bubba
um Parts one and two with the report
provide an overview of actions taken and
delivered to date part three provides an
assessment of the current offer and
parts four and five provide information
about work being explored to further
enhance the offer across the buffer and
that includes a section on financial
considerations committee is us this
evening to note the progress made
to note the progress that has been made
to date to approve phase two of the
electric vehicle infrastructure of all
out and to delegate authority to offices
as appropriate so with that I'll wrap up
if there's any questions I'm happy to
feel then thank you thank you councilor
Williams I think this is a really good
news we are in desperate need of more EV
charging points I think this sets a
clear path that way are there any other
questions from the executive members
it's actually quite an interesting
report and it actually starts uh
obviously a different tangent to our
first report where we're focusing
predominantly on the car perhaps this
one now we're actually starting to look
at some on-street provision which I
think is very important we've said a
number of times particularly those
households uh who do I have uh off
street parking so I think it's a it's a
good report under thank you and put it
together thank you councilor ad said and
we've clearly seen the number of
electric vehicles on our roads increased
in recent years so it is very sensible
for us to take this approach are there
any other questions uh yes councilor
Jerome
thanks leader I've got about seven or
eight questions
so do you want them in two parts or
ideally it wouldn't be seven questions
do you want to do them in two parts and
we'll just see how we get on okay
um table one lift the charge is
installed by Bev across the council and
and private sites to date however the
the five listed on Regent Road aren't
accessible yet
um so we were told the region ones
should be installed in May or June but
when will they be accessible to the
public
um will the charges we're putting in now
be shunned in favor of newer technology
in a few years time
um do we have estimates on how long
these charges will be useful also if you
look at two of the wards uh Clifford has
the
um lowest rates of off-street parking
but currently has no charge points and
Bowden looks likely to be one of the
wards with no charging despite being the
largest there are many residents
especially around bodenvale with no off
street parking are there any plans for
this area and I stopped there and I've
got a few more after that okay I'll go
to council Williams first
thank you counselor for your question in
respect to the first question you've
made around what I propose is if I uh go
away and try and find that information
for you I'll get that sent over to you
via email in terms of new technology
outstripping what we currently have in
place I think you're right to be
concerned about that
um as you'll note in the report that we
are attempting to shift away from
um some of the original technology
towards Ultra fast charging because we
recognize the the technology on offer is
evolving quite quickly and I think what
we'll see is on top of this is that
um the private sector offer will also
start to uh develop a pace now in
respective Clifford and Bowden I don't
have the information off the top of my
head I don't know if Richard if you
wanted to
uh just into
oh it's not on apologies uh respective
region uh Road will work in the
developer of that car park we're
expecting to be open during the course
of this year but there is some final
bits of work still needing to be
required I think on the technology I
think it's a good question but there's
always a bit of dear work for a perfect
solution the technology is going to
change and evolve we could have quite
easily said we're not going to do
anything we'll go as as uh other
colleagues will say we're going to work
whether to see whether it's VHS or B2
Max and see which way we go
um but we didn't think that was
appropriate given the pace of uh
increase abuse of EV
um charging and the in terms of the
rural art and World we've gone we've
been very much followed by where we are
able to install so we're led by well
we've got a capacity and where we've got
land that we're in control of and that's
that's driven the starting point for the
uh for the EV rollout that we've done
because we wanted to deliver that purse
as part of this next verse when we are
looking at other Solutions such as
industry cables cable ends use the lamp
posts that then enables us to look at
other locations including Clifford and
Borden and Ellsworth we are identifying
that were gaps we've got that knowledge
now how do we start to fill those gaps
and whilst not in Clifford I would note
that there is a significant private
sector EV charging Point around half a
mile down the a56 from where we are so
within within a couple of miles of
Clifford Ward
okay thank you Mr Williams thank you uh
Richard
um just this once I'll let you ask your
further questions uh thanks leader
um we've been told in the past that our
lamps didn't have the power to host EV
charging and Trafford now they are being
considered will there be changes to
increase power or
will they not have some fishing power
um the report doesn't mention that the
causeway in ultringham has been removed
from the list of charges have any other
locations listed in the scrutiny report
on January or the previous exec report
been removed if so why and final
question we've been told repeatedly that
decisions about a car club were on hold
until EV charging
um was put in place until it could be
100 electric there was no mention of car
clubs in this report immediately over in
the Manchester border and also in
Salford and there are EV car clubs what
progress is being made on this in
Trafford
Council Williams
thank you um I would defer to the cup of
director place on the technical question
about
um the electrical the electrical
capacity in in our lamp post I know that
not all Sites have the same challenges
do though and so that that is in part
why there's a bit of an inconsistent
offer across the board in terms of
removal of sites again I think I'm
probably going to defer to Richard that
in respect to car clubs
um we have counselors submitted an
expression of interest to joining a car
club that is greater Manchester wide
that work's been undertaken by the
combined Authority I think it's with you
an update later in the summer so most
probably within a couple of months but
um that's certainly not something that
we we've forgotten or has fallen off the
radar thank you thank you councilor
Williams Richard
uh
part of what we're going to be doing at
this next stage is testing the capacity
not it won't work in every areas for us
to be able to use uh street lights for
it depending on the location what the
power supply is in the area that's part
of what we want to to test that they're
all part of the push on this next bit is
for to explore alternative options to
enable us to accelerate a delivery of EV
I will check on the cars where there has
been some changes
um mainly because of power supply from
the original list that went through
screwing the original list that came
through to here to here we're trying to
do this within a deliverable cost
envelope
thank you Richard uh yes councilor
Eckersley
thanks leader
um so a point has been made about new
technology and obstolescence risks uh
however do the council have a vehicle in
place to ensure the proper and Speedy
maintenance of these EV charging points
along with ongoing refurbishments and
upgrading of these charging points as
they become somewhat obsolete due to the
fast changes and improvements in EV
technology
have the council ensured that Bev have
got proper maintenance protocols in
place what is the kpi for getting a
faulty or broken charging Point fixed
and back up and running is this a number
of days or weeks is there anything in
place for that thank you
thank you um Richard
on the uh on the first points of
responsibility for maintaining uh these
is Bev they are Bev uh uh infrastructure
they're not Council infrastructure so
all around their land is with Bev to
maintain them uh so they it's not a kpi
framework but I'll check I'll check
what's in their expectations around time
the time for repairs I don't have that
to end
thank you uh councilor lapori
as to that mine's really easy I saw
Sunday politics yesterday Sunday
politics Northwest had a big
um report on this uh regarding tourist
hot spots in Cumbria and in Lancashire
and my question is uh are we actually
integrating with um with Trafford center
with our two major sports uh hubs with
Dunham Massey uh to actually provide EV
charging with them on their sites moving
forward as well as that part of our
overall strategy as well because we
don't want to lose out on extra tourist
money from people traveling to these
areas thank you uh councilor Williams
thank you councilor for your question
um in terms of
trying to enhance the offer further one
of the things that we have done is
changed guidance from our Planning and
Development management team
um one of the policies that we've
implemented is an expectation that our
new build properties
um electric vehicle charging points
would be included as standard in
respective that specific question around
working for the tourism industry and
working with some of our bigger Partners
I don't know Richard if you've got any
yeah I mean our our starting point is
trying to encourage people not to drive
uh to these uh facilities we've
obviously extend in terms of here with
extended Metrolink through Trafford Park
uh line so there's now a metro stop
right next door to Manchester United
football ground and there also stops at
the Trafford Center and the other line
that stops at the Cricket Club so that
is our starting point
um and also provide other active travel
routes to all those locations including
uh dunamase where we can but we are
talking to Partners in particular
Trafford center around the potential for
uh eBay charging they've got quite a
significant number of EV charging at the
Trafford Center already yeah and we know
that they are Keen to expand that
thank you Richard uh councilor Evans
thank you councilor Ross um
page 20 section 5.2 refers to a pot of
our cash and that's not going to be used
because we're using grant funding and
it's not coming into this year is that
going to be ring fence to move forward
because we will in due course need as
many of these as we can possibly get
certainly the the lamp post ones will
make it a lot easier for people in Terry
streets Etc is it being ring fence and
will it be rolled up into next year or
are we using it elsewhere
thank you uh Richard
uh I mean I would say ultimately that's
a matter for the executive whether
Capital funds uh ring phone star or not
we're trying to deliver this in a way
that minimizes the cost of the council
but accelerates the delivery of of EV
the funding is there uh made it over by
the executive if it was required we
think we can do without it they will
undoubt it'll be a discussion at the
executive when sat in the setting the
capital program for next year whether
there's still a requirement um for that
but I I don't think at this point we can
start to to ring fence uh funding for
next year's Capital program
thank you Richard so I'm oh councilor
wealthy's assistant SEC of seven
questions very quick one okay just
regarding the on-street furniture that
comes with on-street charging
are we uh as a as a council going to be
um focusing on keeping that in parking
base rather than on the pavement
obviously other Council other councils
have had problems with cluttering up the
pavement with a lot of on-street
furniture and really you know I think we
should be prioritizing keeping it on the
road in parking Bays where where
possible is that are we going to be
setting out some recommendations for
this thank you
uh I I think we're aware of we're aware
of the issue where the challenge most of
what we've done has been uh our street
on car parts at the moment that's why
when we're looking at the rollout we're
looking at enabled people domestically
how do that those people without off
Street at car parking they still need to
be able to charge EVS we're looking at
street lights we're looking at
minimizing the amount of Street
Furniture we haven't taken a far more
policy position to say we won't put any
EV charging on the paper but we are
aware of uh the executives wider
Ambitions around insuring accessibility
uh on on our purpose and elsewhere so
it's only something we'll take into
account
thank you Richard so I am going to draw
this item to a close conscious that Rich
has got a lot of corporate directs
replace things on the agenda tonight um
and has already answered quite a bit of
questions on this one um so the
recommendations are a to d as set out in
the report or those in favor
thank you very much so if we move on
then to the highways infrastructure
Asset Management plan and this will be
introduced by the executive member for
highways environmental and traded
Services Steve had said
thank you uh leader yeah I'm pleased to
be opinion this updated report on the
high amp to Executive this evening or
indeed if you mentioned yourself the
highways infrastructure Asset Management
plan for those who may be viewing it and
then go through what this sort of
terminology actually means as you will
note this is an update to report that
come to Executive in 2017 as a 10-year
plan and this is an update to help
ensure the strategy remains robust
relevant and resilient to help ensure we
maintain our category fee status which
helps to ensure Government funding
towards a huge asset which is obviously
in the region of some 1.86 billion which
of course is likely the biggest type of
asset any local Authority is likely ever
to own a half responsibility for as you
all know this is never comprehensive
document covering every aspect of the
highway from signage structures to
Common strategy for the public as well
as members on top of this course the
most important parts obviously highways
footways lighting drainage Etc which are
all extremely important Pence documents
but it's also very positive report and
it's quite clear
our strategy of investing additional
funding towards Capital program above
and beyond that of government funding
has helped provide evidence of health is
assure resilience in the world Network
however like Authority up and down the
country dwelling resources uh the
highway since 2010 have created
deterioration across the network
including nationally of course not just
on our own and of course this is set out
in the book we would need around 72
million pounds to eliminate all such
maintenance issues across the border
including all highways related assets
which are numerous as I mentioned a
moment ago which these scene must be
placed now we should see an increase in
Pothole from northern last year which is
welcome however this in itself should
not be seen as a replacement for the 72
million pound or 30 a moment ago and we
do call on the government to help ensure
that they fund Road repairs properly as
this remains and is of constant concern
to local residents I do though make it
clear that as an Administration we
remain committed to investing above and
beyond Government funding in our roles
and highways through the capital program
and we will use high amp to ensure that
we maximize the benefit from any type of
funding in that respect to ensure our
highways remain safe for all users and
will continue to ensure support for
active travel schemes absolutely support
walking and cycling as a priority thank
you
thank you councilor as I said I mean it
is a very significant figure the total
value the current value of 1.86 billion
of our of our highways infrastructure it
just goes to show how much of it is out
there what a continuous challenge it is
not just here in Trafford but across the
country to make sure it is at a standard
and why this is the right approach the
action that we're taking now to uh to
try and mitigate future pressures so
thank you very much for you in the
offices on work on that do any other
members of the executive have any
questions
okay
um any wider questions uh councilor
frass
thank you leader um the report speaks
about our street trees and the fact they
number in excess of about 20 000 and
their value in terms of things like
biodiversity and their ability to
dissipate water Etc in high rainfall is
only going to increase
climate change is going to make managing
those assets even more difficult because
even in the short time I've been here
I've had trees that are dying in my ward
they need removing or replacing or they
undergo huge growth spurts and trimming
is required what options have we got to
give our tree unit the resources that
they're going to need to actually
maintain that the asset that we have in
terms of Street trees listed in the
report thank you councilor for us
indeeda councilor I said you were
telling me about the impact the recent
weather's been having on our our trees
so do you want to answer Council yeah
climate change is having missing effects
on all parts of our infrastructure
obviously including the trees and and
everything it's a it is something that
we take very seriously and indeed a
report on Highway trees uh you may know
is currently out to public consultation
and of course things like that climate
change I'll address within that quite
apparently there but this is the
overarching strategy the particular
strategy land trees itself so I would
actually you might be better waiting for
that please do take part in that
consultation it's very comprehensive
document and it's a and it should cover
all the points climate change is a very
big factor in that report as well so I
think obviously hopefully that addresses
you because without any particular local
concerns of course do come to us but I
do discuss trees quite regular and
obviously a lack of aim for or too much
rainfall can also affect it as well
either way so there are problems with it
and they treat you and it is so much
aware of these problems and they are
taken into account whatever we can and
they are sort of get to regular
monitoring and indeed when you see the
report that comes out in the author you
actually see that that sort of strategy
is actually dealt with as part of that a
part of that report thank you hopefully
that addresses your concerns thank you
councilor I said councilor Welton
um I was fortunate enough to attend one
of those fascinating seminars on
potholes that we get offered every now
and then in our counselor emails and um
there was a long section in in that
training on on prevention
um for example slower speeds uh reduce
wear on our roads restricting heavy
vehicles on you know on on smaller roads
reduces where limiting through traffic
on residential roads reduces wear and
transition to lighter EVs and e-cargo
bikes for like like last mile delivery
also reduces
um where but I searched through this
document and I didn't find a single
reference to the word prevention or
anything really similar and it just
feels like there's a real there's a
strand to this strategy I appreciate
it's a it's a big issue it's a lot of
money
um and it's a constant challenge given
um the the awful funding on on available
from um uh central government but I
wonder is is prevention something we
should be looking for looking at more
seriously we can actually help ourselves
if we do more do more to reduce the
actual wear on our roads in the first
place thank you thank you uh the
question Council obviously read through
the report obviously all this is also
aligned with tfgm's report on under
structures around those of their
response Dem include in the 20
University strategy and others and of
course all that is aimed at active
travel predominantly courses quite right
we're in that and of course each Road
brings its own challenges obviously uh
there is a hierarchy of roads in terms
from a roads all the way down to
unclassified roads and we want to ensure
that the right strategy is there for
that particular category of Road and
make sure the resources are there to
actually help to maintain it and all
that strategy is outlined say Obviously
in the broader cfgm strategies in that
sense have you got a particular example
we can talk about I know you'll never
complimentally talking of all the things
you mentioned there but obviously uh
they actually all do have an impact and
I think EVS will actually have more of
an impact because they are heavier we
know that in that sense of it but
however it's a
I don't really particularly need to
mention it particularly directly in our
practice but it is predominantly in
their thoughts it isn't in The Wider
strategies that we have in that sense I
don't really need to add anything to the
higher Richard
I think that the high amp is
um quite aware to read as it is already
at councilor welcome with our due
respect to my highways colleagues uh I
think there's a change of putting too
much in I think some of those other
things you've talked about adopting the
administration would would disagree but
we've got active travel working Wheeling
cycle strategies we've got approach
around 20 mile hours on so I think we
are doing those other ones doing other
things I think we'll take it back in
terms of future iterations about whether
we put something that signed posts more
to those prevention activities
thank you Richard A councilor Holden
let's roll the wrong way
yeah it's full of water down the wrong
way I'll do this from a standing
position so it'll be able to shuffle
first of all can I commend the executive
member for this comprehensive
beautifully written report
um unfortunately there's a bear of
little brain it's taking me a little
longer to read it than some of my
younger better educated friends but I
promise you I will read it all one thing
I'd like some guidance on please
although it's elegant although it's
comprehensive I can't find a single
reference to how you're going to measure
success
and how you're going to compare actual
performance with the aspirations set out
in this strategy dog and I appreciate I
may have missed it but I'd like that to
a bit of advice and guidance on that if
I may thank you
yeah if you look through uh various
parts report there are some tables in
the report that actually show obviously
by investing within that I think one of
them is uh
performing by year on page 83 that shows
you that by investing in it you can
actually help and indeed the page place
you've got an 81 to show you the
differences that the peers that you're
invested in show help with the level of
deterioration so obviously we've
invested particularly in the classified
World unclassified roads over the last
year or so and you've seen them actually
come down from 24 in that down to 16 red
so that's each of those years so if
you're looking at particular table there
so I've just outlined on paid a certain
page 81 thing did I say that then you'll
actually see it gives details of Ashley
from ABC an unclassified roles it tells
you by over the last several years
what's actually in there in terms of the
level of deterioration each of the
categories of the danburn green and you
can actually see correlate that to the
expenditure and we know quite easy
actually yeah where the sense is to see
that we're actually helping to support
and maintain those at resilient level
hopefully into the uh amber and so
wherever possible into the green and we
want to avoid the Reds of course and
we're actually invest in that way now to
ensure that we actually keep happening
that should be born out in that sort of
tables that you've seen in there take a
look on page 81 I think it was you'll
see that information there
okay
thank you I mean it is you're absolutely
it's a comprehensive report and I'm I
know we're conscious we're looking at
ways of how to explain the report in in
a much reduced format so um yeah that
would benefit us all I think so um but
thank you for the question thank you for
the answer one last question on this
Council as your own
thanks leader I just wanted to go back
to the um the the tree uh policy that um
councilor frass mentioned
um obviously planting trees on our
highway on our highways is a corporate
policy as well so um the there was a ten
thousand pound cut in the budget for the
highway tree program in uh 2023-24 from
um 20 22 23 that's a 20 reduction in the
in the budget for for the highway Street
uh tree program so it seems penny
pinching in the wrong area to me
considering we're in a climate emergency
but also the residents of Oxford Road
are screaming out for their their roads
to be a no through Road all for there to
be hgv uh restrictions
um it's not Eevee cars the weight of EV
cars that's the problem it's AG hgvs
that tend and oh lgbts and lgbs as well
that are causing the real problems on
our roads and a road like Oxford Road
which is experienced a high volume
volume of hgvs cutting through on that
road that needs to be stopped
thank you leader before I let counselor
I'd said in I just say individual cases
like that please raise them but please
raise them directly with the executive
member outside of this forum councilor
Ed said yes I was going to say Obviously
a particular as you said the South
leader that other Factor needs a big
political case which obviously we're not
uh can't go into that because obviously
it's about the hangout report and that's
entirely separate from that that's
that's actually more of a road safety
matter than a report for the high amp we
do take all such matters seriously and
of course if you were related with
officers and ourselves the normal way
we'll actually see what measures can be
put in there to do that well in terms of
Highway trees yes we do want to see
obviously we can check exactly what the
situation is with trees but I do know
obviously that a lot of our work now is
done through city of trees so whether or
not we can get to try and get the
information for you in that particular
aspect of it but I do know about a lot
of their fumbling and work is now with
citizen budgets in that sense it's only
a small part of the overall budget so
imagine overall we may committed to two
replacing two trees for everyone that
that has to be uh taken out or is lost
and that remains our policy we'll ahead
of time and if we can assist putting
them into residential areas we will do
that indeed there are quite a variety of
schemes including the doctor tree which
I know I'm sure is quite close to your
heart and your residence and it's
something that we fully support I want
to get them out there and obviously
there are a challenge in residential
areas but in many times when we do when
some are lost in the best out streets
it's not always that easy to Simply
replace them in a particular residential
street because of all the additional
utilities that have gone over the past
30 years or so the extra uh not just BT
but all the other cable companies and
others there's a lot more utilities what
used to be now and putting them in some
places cannot always put them in
directly where where people want them to
go obviously we do try and work with
residents and resonance routes to
actually ensure you get as many trees we
place in particularly localities as we
can
thank you thank you councilor ad said
okay so the recommendations are A and B
are set out in the report all those in
favor
okay moving on to item eight which is
the Grafton Center update and the
executive member for economy and
regeneration councilor Liz Patel thank
you leader
in January of last year we set out as an
executive several interventions designed
to prevent further income loss from the
Grafton Center this report today is an
update on progress made alongside a
proposal for the long-term future of the
center
in March 2022 we appointed dedicated
Center management and that has delivered
a much more positive lettings picture
the details of which are set out in
section 2.5 we are delighted to have
welcomed new tenants and to have
established closer working relations
with existing ones as a result our net
property income has increased by just
over 20 percent
in 2022 we also identified the
possibility of using the center as an
event space however subsequent
assessments have shown this not to be
viable at a significant commercial scale
we have also we have instead pursued an
alternative creative approach working
with Ultraman bid and Center managers to
dry foot fall and generate positive PR
for the space through focused art
installations and Community projects and
I believe this is starting on site this
week
as work is soon to complete on our
latest public realm improvements in
Altrincham Town Center we have
identified a number of physical
interventions to improve the external
appearance of the Grafton Center
alongside those works it is envisaged
this will help improve perceptions of
the center in commercial and Community
terms
these interventions have halted the
decline in their income to the point
where we are projecting a modest Surplus
in 23-24
whilst we have been successful in
reversing the declining renting rental
income since acquisition of the Grafton
Center it still faces significant
challenges commercially and in terms of
the physical condition of the building
we do need to determine a long-term
future for the center and therefore
intend to Commission in 2025-26 a future
feasibility study for the Redevelopment
of the center
this will allow us time to fully
understand the impact of investment
elsewhere in alchem and the broader
post-covered economic climate
in the meantime we will continue to look
for Revenue opportunities alongside our
letting Ambitions including potential to
lease and use space for non-retail
purposes
in conclusion I think this is an open
and transparent report back to exec
which presents an overall positive
picture for the Grafton Center in the
short term and outlines a future plan
for the Center thank you thank you
councilor Patel clearly a lot of work
has gone into supporting the Grafton
Center and I am pleased to see that the
asset Center manager has delivered on on
a number of occasions including getting
the vacancy rates right down so that is
that is welcome news and uh I can convey
my thanks to the uh asset Center manager
for that are there any questions from
the executive
okay
um so further uh councilor new grush
thank you thank you for this report
um I am glad to see that the decision to
appoint an ass uh management agent
um has begun to stand the losses from
this investment and we've finally
projected to make a very meager return
in the coming year however this report
is open and clear it's transparent in
the way that of the challenges that this
investment uh has it states quite
clearly that comprehensive Redevelopment
and that was the reason this was
purchased around the existing tenants
would be substantially complex and
expensive process and therefore the
council is looking to con commission
something in the future how does it how
will the basics change in 2526 of the
difficulties you're facing now and if
they aren't going to change that much
why aren't we doing it now
I mean we have faced quite considerable
economic challenges since we acquired
the center
um covid and an economic crisis and
issues around uh you know some of the um
rental returns from some of our main
tenants there that perhaps I couldn't go
into
at this meeting but would have be happy
to discuss with you so we've we've got a
lot going on in Altrincham we're
investing
um in the Stanford quarter into the
public realm into several other sites I
think what's required after that
investment is a is a period of sort of
reflection really on on where we're up
to in terms of how successful or the
impact of that investment I expect
Traders at that end of uh George Street
once Regent Street Car Park is open
we'll
um appreciate a a clear run at trading
with no Works around them
um and so it's a resource issue as well
so we only have a very finite office of
resource and that's quite a significant
piece of work when we're already very
busy as a team so that's
um the challenges that we face and the
reason why we've we're looking now to
commission a feasibility study in two
years time thank you thank you councilor
Patel councilor Evans
thank you leader um
we are we're gonna go out in two years
time for a consultation is what we may
do with this yet we're trying now to
I've got a lot of turning into uh my
colleague here with seven questions but
anyway
um
who would rent it now given in two years
time three years time we're going to be
turfing him out who would commit
investment I know uh I I came across a
business that was prepared to invest 100
000 in one of the one of the uh units
but on that short payback nobody's going
to invest in any of those units because
we're going to be throwing them out
or reviewing throwing them out in in
2025 2026 by the time we've reviewed
that and come to Redevelopment we'll
have owned it 10 years that's just level
of negligence it's just embarrassing
um okay thank you for that counselor
Evans I'm going to ask the councilor to
tell to respond okay
I mean we're not intending to Turf
anyone out
um
I think that's really poor Framing and
you know doing down the good work of not
only this Authority but the the tenants
there
um if you know we are looking at you
know everyone in there is on a flexible
lease Arrangement or the newer ones are
and we will do everything there in
negotiation with our existing tenants
we've got a great team that um looks to
support businesses and help relocation
Etc in our town centers so I think
that's just an appalling framing of what
we're trying to do here thank you
Council so I'm going to go to councilor
butt now
thank you
yeah just a question on the the cost I
know that you've spent uh 122 000 a
ticket on
uh maintaining it so to speak and
there's another 400 000 that you've
allocated from borrowing uh for
additional costs is that as part of you
know the the work that you're going to
do on it the the consultation uh in
terms of what you're going to do with it
is is that going to be paid for through
that is that we allocating that budget
for
the 400k
um will cover uh it's covered the new
management arrangements and um will
cover
um some of these sort of facelift works
and yes I imagine we'll cover the cost
of the um feasibility study
um 122
um is is a loss of uh
a you know a lot of rental income so
that's not a budget associated with it
but the 400k which is why we wanted some
flexibility around that um budget to
allow us to um sort of
tactfully move forward with the grafted
Center and make decisions in a timely
way so yes
thank you and finally councilor Welton
thank you very much I welcome this
report I
um obviously we would love to see you
know you know in altrium the Grafton
Center you know miraculously turned into
something overnight but we understand
it's a very very difficult site
um and you know this needs to be
approached in a grown-up way I think a
couple of years in towards doing things
properly measured in all tears is
actually not very long so um so we you
know we look forward there to that
happening uh eventually
um I think you know the picture in
Ultram is incredibly Rosy at the moment
in terms of lettings of the the the the
bid inform me that there's hardly any
units vacant and actually there's
businesses queuing up food for units
that are not able to find ones because
they're not the right you know not the
right size or shape for their particular
business and this is a really healthy
position to be in whilst they may look
like there's quite a lot of empty units
at the moment actually most of those
units are accounted for so some of the
dire prediction that we've had regarding
the public realm work and the
implications of those have absolutely
not come come to pass um as could have
been
um sensibly predicted
um the only thing about this is is that
Altria does not have any accessible
toilets in the Town Center apart from in
Tesco and this is a this is a crying
shame really and particularly as we you
know it's now a year on since we had the
accessibility reports for our town
centers
um and uh you know I know it's difficult
but this would and I and I see it says
in the in the report that you've looked
into the putting toilets in there I had
hoped there might be some temporary type
facility that we could be able to put in
in you know in one of the units possibly
pixie or or on the other side
um I don't know if that can be reviewed
again because it really is poor we lost
the accessible toilets in region you
know when the Region Road car park was
developed
um and uh it's something we should be
offering people and would generate
football for that end of George Street
as well thank you thank you uh councilor
Patel or Richard
uh
yep thank you um for those positive
comments and for recognizing the
long-term nature of what we're trying to
do here the the Grafton Center was
acquired in February of 2018 so one of
the probably last decisions made by the
last Administration and then we were
very quickly into covid
um which particularly impacted on the
hotel business there
um
I there is no immediate answer to the
lack of public toilets it's a you know a
a dire situation across the country as a
non-statutory provision many areas are
you know under under provided for and I
really accept that that impacts on
people's ability to go about their daily
lives we will be having a new
um accessible toilet and changing
um facility in Ultram Leisure Center
which will be a big plus there
um I'm happy to look into that but I I'm
I know that the cost of
um opening and maintaining those sorts
of facilities are likely unlikely to
make it happen but I'm I'm happy to ask
the question
thank you councilor Patel so the
recommended oh sorry Council Harding
thanks leader I just wanted to come in
on the point about the accessible
toilets and I think
um I'm right in thinking that the age
well board did a mapping exercise on
some of the toilets across the borough
so I think it might be worthwhile
checking out the work of the age World
board because it's been an issue that's
been raised consistently with
um residents across the borough and
you're right so I think it impacts on
people's life daily life their ability
to go about day to day and get out and
about so it might be worthwhile Nathan
if we could just check the work of the
age World board because they did map out
some of the accessible toilets across
the borough thank you
thank you okay thank you very much for
that counselor Harding okay so
recommendations are one two three as set
out in the report all those in favor
thank you so item nine um is the star
procurement collaboration and executive
joint committee paper uh note there is a
part two to this report councilor Patel
thank you from its Inception in 2013 our
shared procurement service star has
expanded from the original local
authorities of Stockport Trafford and
Rochdale to include tameside in 2018
this report outlines the next evolution
of this service with a proposed
expansion to include two further local
Authority Partners taking this to a
collaboration of six councils
our cross-border working arrangements
are set out in an inter Authority
agreement and IAA and the report before
the exec tonight sets out how the
current government governance
Arrangements need to be dissolved and
then re-established by each authority to
accommodate the proposed changes
following any exact approval this
evening this decision will then go on to
full Council in July
this report I believe sets out a
positive case for change an expanded
star could do so much more of the
positive work it's already undertaking
this would include delivering social
value capture on a greatest scale
it would include a full cost recovery
for new partners for the expansion so no
additional costs for existing Partners
critically a bigger group provides a
greater long-term Financial sustain
long-term Financial sustainability for
staff
the collaborative approach already taken
by star has brought sufficient financial
and reputational benefits to the
participating authorities and expansion
provides greater spending power and
influence as being a bigger buyer helps
Drive savings from new and existing
customers
the new authorities bring in new skills
and Workforce diversity to us to start
bolstering the organization as a
national leader in collaboration
at a time when procurement is moving
higher up the political agenda
nationally and at a GM level
it's important to note that we have
already been working well with these two
authorities for some months through
service level agreements and that full
due diligence work has been undertaken
the implementation of this expansion is
complex involved in complex coordination
of the councils involved previous
experience of time size acquisition is
helpful to us new terms of reference
within the inter Authority agreement are
set out within the report the financial
Arrangements associated with its
expansion are also set out within
section 8.3 showing the annual
contributions from new partners which
have been agreed
some staff from these new authorities
will be joining our Workforce here in
Trafford under 2p Arrangements I
understand discussions with HR staff and
trade unions so far has been positive
in a world where local government has
never been under more financial pressure
we see a future in expanding our
procurement and collaborative power to
provide best value
finally I would like to thank the Star
team who have progressed this Expansion
Project alongside the day-to-day service
offer it really has been a tremendous
piece of work to undertake that's
hopefully near completion thank you
thank you councilor Patel and clearly I
was at part of this journey as a as a
Committee Member last year I think as
you say Council Patel there are many
benefits to taking this approach and
growing star and I too would like to put
a record my thanks to the the Tibet star
who do a tremendous job and are really
driving social value which is good to
see noting there's a part two to this
are there any questions from the
executive
okay I'll go to councilor books then
first of all
uh
I mean it has been a success story since
it's in session 2013 and and these
testimony the fact that it keeps growing
and taking on more Partners as time goes
on I think that worry is I mean the
ethos uh at the time in his early days
was that it was to benefit local
suppliers Regional suppliers and pre uh
during the EU period there was also
complaints that anybody any company
within the EU 27 members could uh apply
for any procurement contracts that came
up at that time obviously post brexit
now that isn't the situation but it used
to be a complaint of a company's
surprise
I think my point I want to make is that
how are you going to still support local
businesses smes Regional suppliers
because that's the the procurement
becomes a bit of a monolith much bigger
and it'll be procuring in much larger
quantities and services that the smaller
players maybe get left behind and not be
able to compete so I think that's my
concern that we don't lose that ethos
and still maintain our connections with
local suppliers and service providers so
they can still have that Level Playing
Field okay thank you
thank you for your question
um important points that you raise
um
local suppliers and supporting smes do
remain at the core of the offer here at
Star I think one of the the themes of
the sort of the discussions
um that have gone in the last sort of 12
months or so has been around the
potential for this expansion to for us
to lose sight of those original
um you know that original purpose for
the vehicle so we've been
uh very comprehensively sort of
reinforcing that original
um
um sort of agenda really if you look
online at the march at the last March
star meeting we had a dedicated report
on small medium businesses
um we've met with Robert Downes
um who's the local
um small business Federation rep and
we've we're actually taken on board some
very practical Solutions about how we
encourage smaller businesses to to bid
for contracts and and what support we
can offer for them it's certainly
something that Trafford takes seriously
and another key Partners take seriously
too so um we are revisiting and
maintaining and reinforcing the original
concept of Star as we start this sort of
expansion piece of work
go on just to say that I mean as the as
the organization grows quite
considerably is there an opportunity for
one of the other party members to be
able to join the the committee or
something or at some point I mean
obviously it's your decision but I mean
I just thought
I I think the governance Arrangements
have been all set out in this report and
that remains that an exact rep from each
um Authority attends the joint The Joint
board
um yeah is it broadcast it wasn't last
time it's not ordinarily is it no but we
are minuteed and they are shared online
and you would be welcome at any time if
you wanted to get in touch with me or
submit questions I'm sure we could um
get that through I mean approach uh you
know it's Trafford that runs this
service they're our staff so if you've
got any questions it's Lorraine it's
Lorraine Cox who's very approachable
um you know it might even be that we've
probably overdue a bit of a
a sort of a a training session or an
update session that we can invite
members to perhaps um I think I had that
back in 2019 before covid so I think
it's probably time to revisit that
yeah I I think that's a a good point
there are lots of opportunities I know
and those that know Lorraine will know
she's very passionate about procurement
and start and she would give lots of
time to explaining update members as to
where star is where it's going and the
achievements that it's had so yeah that
that's something to consider and also of
course if complexions of councils change
within the star Arrangement then of
course the the the the the balance
changes changes on there as well so you
know we had that recently with Stockport
where um we have a a liberal Democrat in
the exact role now because it's
obviously a controlled by by them so it
does it does change over time the
complexion
um but clearly I know that Lorraine and
the team of star would be very happy to
update members so um I'm gonna move on
if that's okay Council but two it's
Council Jerome you had you indicated
didn't you
thanks chair
um local Authority Supply chains are
estimated to account for up to 90 of
their total carbon footprint
this report only
um ensures that its procurement
activities are conducted with a focus on
sustainable practice so I just wondered
why there's no detailed document that
outlines our strategy and approach to
sustainability when it comes to Star and
why there's no carbon accounting on
these ongoing contracts
a carbon reduction measures are are part
of the the social value element that we
um
that we apply and I'm happy to go back
to Lorraine and ask for more details on
that you're right it's not captured
ordinarily but we do report back in
meetings on that element so it is
alongside other elements taken seriously
now and that agenda certainly is being
set at a GM level
thank you and councilor Acton
yeah that's thank you lead it
um clearly scrutiny does look at this
issue every year through the budget
process and we you know we're very keen
to look at the performances uh and I
think any member is allowed to come to
that which I think is enlightening
thank you that's that's a good point it
may be that the scrutiny committee wish
to consider the expansion book that's
for the scrutiny committee members to
decide not to not the executive but it's
Food For Thought okay so the
recommendations in this part are one and
two are set out in the report all those
in favor
thank you very much so now we move on to
item 10 which is the Trafford design
guide and code and I'll pass over to
council Elizabeth Patel again thank you
leader
I am delighted to present this report
today which have approved marks one of
the final stages in adoption of our new
traffic design code it's a way to report
on appendices as is often the case with
planning policy development so to
highlight so I will highlight just a few
key points
as a new Administration we recognized
early on that good design in our built
environment matters work began in 2019
on the Trafford design guide developing
a first draft on which we had to pause
work when we entered the pandemic this
project was picked up again in Spring of
21 and so by July 21 when the government
announced their intention to run a
design code Pathfinders program Trafford
was in an excellent position to
successfully apply
Grant monies from that program have
enabled us to develop and sustain
in-house skills and support for this
huge piece of work skills that will
benefit our planning service moving
forward
an extensive piece of work has been done
around the public about around public
engagement with the design code I've
personally enjoyed going out to
communities and groups and talking
design with residents a subject that can
seem complex and Out Of Reach but that
touches every people's people's everyday
lives people were very keen to have
their say
attached to this paper is a weighty
document which sets out the latest draft
in a PDF format format a better way to
use the code is online through our
interactive accessible digital platform
which is being used nationally as an
Exemplar it is envisaged moving forward
that this is the format developers and
residents will engage and one that we
are Keen to promote it's intended that
our traffic design code will be adopted
as supplementary planning document and
will be a material consideration in the
determination of planning applications
it therefore represents a clear message
to developers that we are raising the
bar in Trafford following any approval
today we will launch the final
consultation draft for a further six
weeks alongside some community and
developer drop-in events it is expected
to proceed to final adoption in the
Autumn when I will return to report back
to exec finally I would like to thank
our planning team led by Rebecca Coley
for the tremendous amount of work that's
gone into this they should rightly feel
proud as we are as an administration of
the groundbreaking work that's been
undertaken here the adoption of the
Trafford design guide will have a
positive impact in Trafford for many
years to come thank you
thank you councilor Patel I cannot
stress enough how important this
document is to us all in this
Administration it is a considered
comprehensive report and councilor Patel
is quite right the digital platform if
you've not had a look it's well worth
having a look and the other element
about it not just how interactive it is
but also the accessibility measures that
have been put in there to make it as
accessible as possible to our local
residents
this will help us once we get through
this next stage to the final stage as
councilor Patel says this will help us
set our high expectations as an
Administration to the developments that
we want to see for our local residents
in this Borough it is crucial that we
have those high expectations because our
residents deserve the best from planning
and Urban Design and this will help us
deliver this and forgive me for
repeating uh councilman Patel but I also
want to put my thanks on record to
Rebecca Coley and all the team in
planning and development who've worked
incredibly hard to deliver what is a
very high quality document which I know
will be used very well once it gets to
that final stage later this year
are there any other questions Council
Williams
um thank you chair I just also wanted to
reflect on what's a new good news story
this is for Trafford and we've spoken
previously of our status as one of the
20 poorest-funded local authorities in
the country which often means that our
departments do not enjoy resource levels
appreciated by other councils serving
comparable population sizes so it really
does speak volumes about the competence
and hard work of officers that we
successfully bit to be part of the D
look Pathfinders program
we've seen recently some high quality
new build developments my own personal
favorite being number one Old Trafford a
very Northern edge of the border and the
challenge for us to the council is to
secure a similarly high quality of
design across the rest of the borough
hopefully this design guide will assist
with that challenge thank you Chad thank
you
um councilor Harding
thank you leader I too want to put on
record
um thanks to Rebecca and the team I
think this brings planning alive really
I think the digital platform actually is
really easy to use it does bring design
alive and I think traffic should be very
proud of the work that has gone into
this so yes my thanks to all the team
thank you thank you very much are there
any other questions uh councilor Welton
oh yeah this is a fantastic document
obviously we want it to be seen by as
many people as possible in the
consultation to be as far-reaching as we
can
I know that there's there's been several
rounds of consultation that have gone
into this already the first one had its
own website all the dates for the con
for the consultation events were on
there it was really easy to find the
second round the the dates never made it
to that first website and when I wanted
to attend one of those events I had to
scroll all the way through a whole load
of council
um uh you know the whole the council's
Facebook feed
um to find a post that I'd vaguely seen
um which had the dates in them um so
just really want to make sure that we
that we make it very clear have a very
definite place where these where these
dates uh are held so that we as
councilors can point people towards them
um I presume this sorry I haven't been
on the digital portal yet I presume it's
all going to be on uh on there I look
forward to seeing that
um but yes just uh let's get it right
this time thank you
thank you for that Council Patel
um I'm sorry you couldn't
um access that sort of second stage very
easily the the second stage was a more
focused and targeted
um consultation so we deliberately
approached groups
um interest groups uh directly we will
be publishing a full summary of the
consultation process in the Autumn when
we come back again as part of the
adoption of the policy what I would say
is that this final six weeks aren't a
revisit of the broad principles we've
already established
um so uh in comparison to the last
stages it won't be as extensive in terms
of the events that we're putting on but
certainly I will make sure that members
in the public is is widely advertised
for as much interest as possible thank
you thank you and councilor frass
thanks leader there's clearly been a lot
of work to produce and codify this it
actually was really quite interesting to
read uh we can't discuss every details
so perhaps I'll zoom in on one detail
and then zoom out with a big picture
question last week at planning training
I went along we saw all sorts of
pictures of exciting new build Estates
but the reality is they never look like
the artist's impression because the
entire Street Scene is littered with
with cars they make it difficult for
pedestrians to cross difficult for
wheelchair users buggies visually
impaired people
um not to mention dangers for cyclists
with parked cars and I was just struck
by the preference in the report for
on-street parking and it was dealt with
sympathetically and intelligently but I
couldn't find any mention of what could
we not encourage some off-street parking
in this new design code for brand new
builds that would also help with the
electric vehicle stuff we we discussed
at the beginning and then zooming out
big picture question realistically with
trafford's housing shortage the tilt
balance that we are taught so much about
in favor of development and the
difficulty of enforcement what chance
have we got of getting big developers to
stick to our lovely new design code
thank you councilor for us uh councilor
Patel
just to the second part of that the
design code will be integrated with our
planning application validation
checklist and so
um unless
applicants demonstrate that they have
um complied with the code or referenced
the code then their application won't be
validated won't be processed we also
have been working very closely with
developers you'd imagine they've got a
lot to say on this and we will be
meeting them as an Architects and
developers Forum
um
during this next phase of consultation
but yes it does represent a challenge to
the standard model of house building
that we've seen in the past and I think
that will take time for developers to to
get used to but we're determined that
we're going to raise the bar and apply
that through our planning making
decision processes and our enforcement
processes the parking Point
um I'm not sure overall we're trying to
um reduce the Reliance on cars and you
know not prioritize parking over
um Street Scenes Etc and that is
reflected in this design code where new
builds we're not encouraging on-street
parking around new builds
um in fact the opposite we're looking
um to generate to create landscape
frontages alongside side parking and
there's a whole section on that
um
Street Scene and hierarchy and who has
you know the priority in design terms
and ultimately that's people and that's
what this design code is about
thank you councilor Patel okay there are
a series of recommendations set out as
bullet points at the start of this
report all those in favor
thank you very much so item 11 which is
the period 12 budget monitoring report
for 2022-23 and I'm going to introduce
the executive member for finance change
and governance councilor Harding thank
you leader
um I am presenting the report for noting
this evening budget monitoring period
12.
um
clearly it is always positive when we
are saying that we are balancing The
Prudent budget and there is some
underspend which is noted in the budget
but I am obviously going to say that I
present this with a word of caution
there are um the other thing I wanted to
say really I'm delighted with the new
format of the report and I wanted to
give my thanks to Graham and his team
one of the things I I've been Keen to do
really is to make sure that we have
Finance in a more accessible format it's
incredibly complex local government
finances incredibly complex to
understand and I think it's important
that we present it in a way that's easy
to read and easy to question so I
definitely like the new format of the
report really
so the recommendations are that you note
the report and that note the underspend
of 56 000 and that has been transferred
to our budget Reserve
um note the reserves in section four and
note the capital program as I said
really the sections are outlined for you
to read and I I will assume that the
exec and Shadow exec have read
um the risk areas clearly are inflation
and interest rates which will continue
to be a challenge for us
um the pay award which Trafford is
having to make sure that we budget
sufficiently for those are some of the
challenges
um the ongoing kind needs block of the
budget for schools present those
challenges and so
we and we've also noted risk at the
Trafford Center where we've put some
money aside around the business rate
risk Reserve so I'm going to leave it at
that
um we have topped up reserves
um and it's it's basically outlined in
the report and it's for noting so any
questions from exec or other thank you
very much councilor Harding and can I
add my thanks to both Graham Bentley and
Dave magrudge as well for their Sterling
working of them and all their team over
the last year
um clearly there were challenges with
inflation inflation is still around
double-digit figure
interest rates are creeping up which
have their indirect effects on us as
well as their Direct effects on us but
at the end of this we did balance the
budget with a slight under spend and we
have added to our reserves because we're
mindful that the challenges continue
into next year and that is what sound
financial management is all about are
there any questions from other executive
members
okay any wider questions councilor but
thank you chair uh I'm just gonna pick
on one point I think of that all right
let's uh the under Section six of the
report uh Capital program it shows an
under spend of uh 0.98 million in the
highways budget for that uh for the last
Financial year 22-23 and the brothers
roads uh quite a few of them have got
potholes in them the delaminated
surfaces and yep we've had almost like a
million pounds uh in the highways budget
that wasn't spent so why was that budget
why was that money in the highways
budget not used during the last
Financial year to improve the roads that
residents have constantly been
complaining about okay before I bring
you in because because I'm conscious of
some of the things that took place as
part of the budget last year
um we're conscious of slippage in the
capital budget which is one of the
reasons we put steps in
um recently to have regular meetings to
keep a track of how that budget is spent
idea of course we want to make sure it's
spent well you may have seen already
this new Financial year a lot of
treatments Road resurfaces has started
going already as we look at the
different way that we manage our capital
budget so it has turned a corner in
terms of the the way we manage it
clearly there is more to do and I won't
steal any more of council Harding's fun
to pass over to you no thank you
councilor Ross and I think I was going
to say really there is the bit about how
we identify those roads that falls under
some casework Council abort and I think
it's important to make sure that all of
those I myself as award counselor will
identify roads that are in need of
attention it goes forward to the capital
program criteria is applied as to the
roads that need to be repaired but let's
be realistic I think as
um councilor Williams referred to really
we are one of the 20 poorest funded
local authorities and I think that the
work that we manage to do Under the
current climate and the issues that we
face as a local Authority yes it isn't
um you know it isn't ideal and the
things that we would like to do facing
old infrastructure but the fact is we do
have a capital program there's criteria
applied if you have specific areas that
you would like to put forward please do
that via the correct process thank you
councilor button okay thank you I don't
know Richard if you want to say anything
more on the capital perspective if
yeah I think just to say she said uh
later we have made uh significant
improvements in the delivery of the
capital program this year overall we've
put in place measures to ensure that we
do that and I do believe all that uh
that uh 0.98 million uh under spent in
year uh is work that's being carried on
during this year that we all know that
the end of March is is there something
of an arbitrary uh deadline the world
doesn't stop at the end of the March so
some things do inevitably carry over the
12-month uh period but I think we have
made significant improvements in
delivery uh the executive and the
council approved the capital program for
23.24 including the full detailed
program at budget which meant that we
were on the ground delivering that
program in April of this year we would
hope that 12 months from now when we're
looking at the period 12 or 23 24 that
that underspend will be significantly
reduced thank you Richard I'm bringing
Council Harding again
um and just to say I think as counselor
Upton referred to at the beginning the
scrutiny process will take place of
course where we'll be looking at some of
those decisions that are coming forward
and how I as the exec the finance as
well as all the other exec members can
come forward and have those discussions
with scrutiny which are of course
cross-party where we're able to have
some of those very Frank discussions at
the scrutiny process
but thank you so the recommendations are
set out as a to c at the front of this
report or those in favor
thank you very much so item 12 I've got
no urgent business so I am now going to
proceed to read the exclusion resolution
so bear with me as ever with this one
let's clear my throat there we go but
the public be excluded from this meeting
during consideration of the remaining
items on the agenda because of the
likelihood of disclosure of exempt
information which Falls within one or
more descriptive category of all
categories of the local government at
1972 schedule 12a as amended by the
local government access to information
variation order 2006 and specified on
the agenda item or report relating to
each of such item respectively Alex are
we now off air